good morning Hank it's Monday I spent
much of this weekend in New York Central
Park and for some reason I kept thinking
of my favorite photograph so there was
this German photographer August sander
who's famous for his massive never
finished series people of the 20th
century in which he took pictures of
everyone from bricklayers to circus
performers to famous composers along the
way he also took my favorite picture
this one which is sometimes known as
three farmers on their way to a dance
1914 there's a lot I like about this
picture I like how the farmers heads are
cut off by the horizon I like how their
faces are in the sky but their feet are
in the mud and I like what the
photograph tells us about class and
history that by 1914 mass production
meant that these young farmers could
afford suits and fancy hats and canes so
the first time in history European
peasants in the countryside could dress
like are almost like urban professionals
but then again they're still walking
rather than driving in a car these are
young men on the cusp of what I think of
as the contemporary world and I like how
they're looking over their shoulders as
if they can only briefly pause for the
camera before they head off to their
futures to the dance it was the middle
of 1914 and these three farmers were of
course on their way to two dances the
one they knew about and World War one
these men very likely ended up fighting
in that war and they may well have been
among the 17 million people who died in
it and the very same industrial
manufacturing innovations that made
their clothes affordable created the
bullets and machine guns that made World
War one so lethal the three people in
this photograph are living in the middle
of history like to us the dance they
were walking toward seems inevitable but
to see their faces is to know that it
wasn't that history is choices we
collectively make about how to look at
the world and how to respond to what we
see these three young farmers walking
along a road in the germ investor vault
101 years ago remind me that I am also
in the middle of history and that how I
imagined the world and the people in it
really matters someone once told me that
photographs are just light and time and
in this picture August sander captured a
hell of a light and a hell of a time I
pray we never see the likes of it again
Hank I'll see you tomorrow